jean isabelle oui ça va et toi
sabah des vacances tes vacances vacances
vacances de super vacances super
vacances d'accord calais ou en vacances
ou tu allais ou aux vacances moi j'ai
pris l'avion et je suis allé voir la
tour eiffel
tu veux aller à la montagne tu es parti
à la montagne montagne non voilà je vois
pas je suis monté un ascenseur à
l'ascenseur tu as pris l'ascenseur
d'accord c'est ouvert à j'ai vu de
belles choses jolies séjour de la maison
d'accord la tour eiffel tu vas aller à
la tour eiffel d'accord la tour eiffel
hockey et il y avait du soleil il
faisait beau il y avait du soleil à
l'instauration soleil oui non il faisait
pas beau il y avait plein de nuages du
vent et il faisait froid il faisait
froid
d'accord très franchement j'ai aussi
pris plein de photos as-tu appris plein
de photos jolivel photo tu veux les voir
à je veux bien
ah oui j'ai envie bonjour je suis sourde
vacances avions tour eiffel soleil
nuages
vent
froid
photo au revoir